Demon's creepy teens and a guy whose
hobby is making these really creepy
masks Kieran is the latest supernatural
show from Netflix Europe joining the
likes of Aras Ragnarok and my personal
favorite dark so in this video we'll be
taking a look at the mystery surrounding
the curse of Kieran how the supernatural
entity works and why I think this is one
of the darkest TV endings ever and if
you want to skip right to that I've left
a link in the description but before we
begin please take a second to like and
subscribe with the Belon because here we
go a creepy bell tower submerged by
water is a great setting for a horror
show and it's this tower where the
legendary curse of Kieran stems the town
of Kieran used to belong to Austria
that's why you have families like the a
Spurs who sometimes speak German to one
another but the town eventually came
under Italian control causing friction
between the families who lived there
most of whom were Austrian in fact a
2011 census stated that 97% of the
population of Kieran speaks German to
make matters worse an Italian family by
the name of Ramos decided to flood the
town to make way for the construction of
a hydroelectric dam this caused an even
greater divide between members of the
town resulting in the curse of Kieran
according to the legend in retaliation
for flooding the town the spirits of the
dead come back to haunt the town's folk
for allowing this to happen
and the Rena spam lis are the ones to
blame until every member of their family
is dead the curse will remain it's said
that when you hear the bell of the
submerged clock tower you're the next
one to die which makes it even more
interesting that the first thing we hear
in the show in episode 1 is a bell tower
chiming as we find out through the
season the curse is very much real the
lake creates a copy of a townsperson to
fully take over their lives but it
doesn't just take anybody it takes
someone's whose life is being repressed
in one way or another
in episode 5 Thomas explains that man is
created in two parts ourselves and a
shadow normally these two parts live
peacefully side-by-side but sometimes
one tries to overpower the other which
causes it's a victim to hear the bells
of the church tower these copies will
stop at nothing to fully take over their
subjects lives to bring balance to
whomever's life they've come for for
example Lucas is depicted as a wimp he's
constantly bullied and doesn't even have
the courage to defeat his clone when it
attacks the clone however is a badass
who takes matters into his own hands and
isn't afraid to get his hands dirty
each of these clones are trying to fix
something missing from their copies
lives even if that means killing to do
so as we later find out these copies can
be killed but they simply reemerge from
the lake brand-new if that happens this
is why Thomas kept the clone copy of an
ax in his attic for 17 years he knew
this copy if left unattended would
search relentlessly for the real Annie
if he didn't do something so he kept it
chained away the perfect encapsulation
of this is the wolf Thomas has chained
outside his hotel he thinks these copies
can be quote domesticated and as we
learn through the character of Albert
yes these clones can completely take
over the lives of their victims as a
teen Albert was in love with Anna but
Anna wanted to be free leave Kieran and
move away
she even cheated on him with a man will
later find his petrol she says she's
pregnant and that Albert is not the
father but what if Anna was lying about
this what if Albert was the real father
I actually thought this would tie into a
huge reveal at the end of the season but
that didn't happen
that would mean that Daria and Mauro are
Albert's kids making them half siblings
with Mickey and Giulio and if you've
seen the entire season that would mean
Daria and Giulio hooking up would mean
some serious incest after getting dumped
a young Clara takes Albert out on the
lake to console him she's in love with
him but Albert's heart belongs to
Annagh suddenly albert is attacked by
his copy resulting in his death and the
new albert takes over a copy who doesn't
care if he makes it with clara something
the real albert would never have done
eventually they'll marry and have two
kids Micky and Giulio Clara keeps it a
secret because she finally gets what she
always wanted to be with Albert even if
it's all a lie
later in the season when Clara is
confronted by a copy of herself she
doesn't fight it
she knows her life has been one big lie
her romance with Albert was never real
she'd rather be dead than live with this
lie onward to the beginning of the last
episode titled the maze this is a
reference to the series of tunnels and
bunkers constructed by the Italians
during World War two in the event of an
invasion the characters often refer to
it affectionately as the plains of the
dead the real Anna has been held captive
by her copy and conveniently there's a
piece of wire she uses to escape in an
ironic twist Tomas last episode was held
captive in the same attic he held Anna's
copy and he's put in there with the wolf
he's able to fight it off and sets it
free the kids who are composed of Daria
maro Miki and Giulio travel up the
mountain in search of their parents
Thomas and clone Clara team up as well
in search of the kids who they know will
be in danger from Albert and Albert is
continuing his love affair with Anna
what these two don't realize yet is
their love is a lie to the real Albert
fell in love with the real Anna but
these two are both copies they're not
the same people this will come into play
a bit later meanwhile the kids find the
entrance to the tunnels and uncover a
pile of Bones they believe it could
belong to Italian soldiers who were
defending the tunnels but as we learn
the Nazis never ended up invading so why
are there dead bodies it's almost as if
the writers were like hey wouldn't it be
cool if they stumbled upon some bones
but they never explain it well coming up
the side of the mountain Thomas and
Clara uncover the bodies of Lucas and
Berger who were killed last episode
burger was Thomas's best and only real
friend and Kieran and this Lucas was the
evil clone of the real one which begs
the question can a clone come back if
its original has already been killed
this is never really explored in the
show but
I think not a copy can't be created
without an original so Lucas is now
likely gone for good
the Albert and Anna clones find out that
the real Anna has escaped remember how I
said that their love is a lie since
they're both clones well here is where
we learn why the Anna clone wanted to
kill the original right away but at the
orders of Albert had held her captive in
the tunnels so she would starve Anna
accuses Albert that this was his plan
all along that he never wanted to kill
Anna because that's the real woman he
fell in love with clone Anna bashes her
head into the wall in an attempt to
trick the kids into thinking she was the
one held captive and the kids aren't
really dumb and gets split up in the
creepy World War two tunnels where they
just saw a bunch of human bones Daria
and Morrel finally to Anna's separately
but then the question remains who is the
real Anna and this is where this series
goes extremely dark so dark in fact that
this has to be one of the saddest most
tragic endings I've ever seen in the
seasons climax Daria and Morrel have to
figure out which of their mothers is the
real one and to make matters worse
Albert appears aiming his gun Albert has
realized that neither one of the Anna's
are his Anna the clone Anna is simply
that a clone and the real Anna he never
fell in love with because he's a clone
himself it was the original version of
him that fell in love with that Anna the
two and his fight each other and Albert
ends up shooting both of them and to
make things even more twisted he shoots
himself in front of his own kids so
right off the bat we have a double
murder-suicide in front of some kids but
it gets even worse
one of the Anna's survives and escapes
as we'll find out this is Anna's clone
but her escape is short-lived as Mauro
tracks her down and holds her at
gunpoint she tries to explain herself
that the real Anna was weak and couldn't
protect them from their abusive father
earlier in the season we learned that
Mauro's hearing loss was caused by his
father when he pushed young Mauro
causing him to bonk his head and lose
part of his hearing and his clone was
simply a protector that's why she killed
their father in cold blood
Anna ends up falling over the edge of
the cliff plummeting to her death as her
family watches on and that's just part
of what makes this ending so dark first
we have Daria and Mauro lose both of
their parents even witnessing the death
of their mother
in person Miki and Giulio watches their
father murders the Anna's then takes his
own life in front of them Clara later
shows them the grave of the real Albert
and the kids find out that their father
was one of these evil copies their
entire life not to mention their real
mother is dead and they're left with
this copy of their mom if that isn't
enough a character by the name of Ober
brings Lucas's dead body to his father
'über isn't given much screen time
throughout the season but he's part of
this rival family that once held control
over Kieran but when Kieran was part of
Austria his family held sway so he's got
some personal vendetta against the
Terrenas
he says that the lake has awoken once
again and that the Reynes must be
destroyed Mickey and Aria start to hear
the sounds of the bell tower meaning
copies of themselves are on their way
but since the lake is frozen the copies
are trapped even though their copies
it's still terrifying to watch as they
pound on the ice gasping for air but if
there's a season two it's most likely
that these copies will find their way
out from the frozen lake Curran is a
deeply tragic series with almost all of
its characters losing the most important
people in their lives even Thomas loses
his best friend and daughter but more
tragic is that I personally didn't feel
connected to any of the characters and
at times the writing feels contrived and
forced in order to make the plot work
most of the twists are predictable in
the show and there weren't any major
holy [ __ ] moments that define many of
these types of shows but if you're
desperate to have something to tide you
over until the new season of dark comes
out give this one a try thank you for
watching and if you haven't done so
already please make sure to LIKE and
subscribe and for more bat takes you can
follow me on twitter at big story whitey
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much